why would the mcu's latest villain join
forces with Earth's Mightiest Heroes
believe it or not the pieces are all
there let's dive in but watch out these
waters are teeming with spoilers Namor
first appeared in the 1939 Marvel Comics
number one issue and it's safe to say
the character has been involved in more
comics than many of the more well-known
characters in the Marvel roster since
these storylines haven't yet been part
of the MCU though not everyone is aware
of them but after the revelation of
Namor and talocon in Black Panther
wakanda forever the possibilities for
his future are as Limitless as the Seas
themselves they called him
when Neymar was first introduced he was
an adversary of the Android Human Torch
who was later reimagined by Stanley and
Jack Kirby as Johnny Storm of the
Fantastic Four in 1961's Fantastic Four
number four Neymar made his return not
only as the Rival of the Human Torch but
of the Fantastic Four as a whole with
Namor being a sometimes Ally sometimes
foe of Doctor Doom the rumors of Doctor
Doom as the villain in the Fantastic
Four 2024 film reboot race is the
possibility of Namor being a part of
that storyline as well a second route
for Namor would be for him to become
part of the Illuminati the Earth 838
group that the Scarlet Witch decimated
in Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness the Illuminati
will see you now
the illumawati this group hasn't been
formed yet on Earth 616 but after
meeting them in the alternate universe
it's possible that doctor strange could
decide to form his own Illuminati of
which Neymar was shown to be a member in
New Avengers number seven a third
possibility could be further off with
Neymar playing a role in Avengers the
Kang Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars
both of which he plays a part in in the
comics while Namor has professed in
Black Panther wakanda forever to wanting
to keep his kingdom secret and his
people safe certain events could push
him to take an unexpected role as an
Avenger in 1985's Avengers number 262
Namor lost his kingdom and was pushed
out as their ruler leaving him adrift
and unsure about his future he came
across the Avengers on hydro base in a
despondent State and Captain America
wanting to help him find purpose asks
him to become an Avenger in Black
Panther wakanda forever Neymar's cousin
disapproves of his decision to Ally with
wakanda at the end of the film so it's
possible a mutiny could be on the
horizon the teleconil could rise up and
force any more out leading him to become
an Avenger Namor far Kang alongside
Captain America and Captain Marvel in
the 1986 issue Avengers number 268 in an
attempt to rescue wasp Black Knight and
Hercules with the introduction of
Hercules and Thor love and thunder a
sneak peek of Black Knight in the
eternals and Michelle Pfeiffer resuming
her role as the original wasp in the
upcoming Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania all of the elements needed to
recreate the events of the Kang Dynasty
are already being introduced into the
MCU an attack or even just the threat of
an attack on talocon could be enough to
push Neymar into the Avengers in an
attempt to protect his people while
Marvel Studios is notoriously secretive
about their plans for future films and
television shows it's clear from the
previous phases that everything fits
together perfectly in the end we may not
be able to see the completed puzzle and
where all the characters fall into place
yet but there's certainly a strong
possibility that the mcu's most recent
antagonist could one day join Earth's
Mightiest Heroes